it's a very great honor of tonight's  nominees for Best Direction John  Schlesinger nominated for Midnight  Cowboy has told us how he started Arthur  Penn for Alice's Restaurant began as a  director of army films Sydney [ __ ]  they shoot horses don't they was an  actor George Roy hill Butch Cassidy and  the Sundance Kid was a writer and a  Broadway director costa-gavras of Z was  an assistant director who wrote his own  screenplay to get started the winner is  the winner is John Schlesinger  John wishes he could have been here  tonight he's right in the middle of the  shooting his next motion picture Bloody  Sunday and I think he's on the phone in  the back before him I'd like to say this  he'd like to thank James Leo Herlihy for  his novel and all his American friends  who made him feel so at home and worked  so hard for something he cared so very  much for thank you